Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my video all about the new
version of thor's hammer during thor 4 love
and thunder we finally have some new scenes
that actually explain how the new hammer exists
within the movie because i know there's a big
question about where the alternate versions of the
hammer are going to come from if you're brand new
to my channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos i'll be doing marvel movie videos
all year for all the new movies that are coming up
in marvel phase 4 in all the marvel phase 4 disney
plus series episodes and speaking of thor related
stuff the next big marvel disney plus series is
loki we're going to get episodes of that in a
couple weeks but currently thor love and thunder
is still filming so you've all probably seen the
videos and the pictures from the set in your feeds
even director taika watiti has been posting
pictures from behind the scenes in the set
this is him letting his kids just check everything
out i will explain what they're actually filming
in these scenes that he was posting later in
the video because they aren't directly related
to the new version of thor's hammer the new
version of mjolnir that they have in the movie
technically it's actually the new old hammer
because jane foster thor female thor whatever
you want to call her during the film will wield
a version of the hammer so when they announced it
at comic-con and taika handed her the prop replica
of mjolnir and said they were doing a story based
on the mighty thor from the comics and gore the
godbutcher storylines everyone was just wondering
how they would explain the other hammer because
the last we saw hella smashed mjolnir during thor
ragnarok in the second version of mjolnir that
thor wielded during avengers end game he actually
stole that from the events of thor of the dark
world it was a great scene it was a funny moment
but after the battle was over captain america took
that hammer back to asgard during the events of
dark world when he took all the infinity stones
back so after avengers end game they don't have
that second hammer anymore i get so many questions
about that when i talk about thor love and thunder
and the alternate version of the hammer like don't
they have a second hammer already didn't thor
have one no they took that one back i guarantee
you people are still going to be confused about
that when the movie picks up i think people just
forgot about this captain america scene with him
taking the hammer back because by this point
in the film even when they're re-watching it
they kind of checked out because you're still
kind of thinking about iron man dying and all the
other stuff that was going on because there was so
much stuff going on in that film i've already done
videos for the other first looks that we got at
thor the guardians of the galaxy during the movie
and the new version of that fake play that they're
doing with matt damon's character the fake version
of loki luke hemsworth chris hemsworth's real
life brother playing the fake version of thor sam
neil came back as odin and now they have melissa
mccarthy playing fake hella and they're parodying
the events of thor ragnarok with her breaking the
hammer and of all the moments in the film there's
an important reason why they're parroting this
particular scene that relates to the new version
of mjolnir that jane foster wheels during the
movie i'll explain in a second but i'll post links
to those other videos for the other footage down
in the description below recently though there
were other scenes they were filming near this area
of new asgard where this big stage is outside that
explain where that new version of thor's hammer
comes from and clarifies how it's going to work
during the movie because in the mighty thor comic
book that they're partly using his inspiration for
the story of the film the whole reason why
jane foster became thor in the first place
is because thor odin's son this version of
thor became unworthy and couldn't lift the
hammer anymore in the whole idea was there must
be a thor to protect asgard but after avengers
end game and at the beginning of thor love and
thunder so it seems main thor is still worthy so
we can tell he still has stormbreaker which is
supposed to be even more powerful than mjolnir
so they have to have some other way of explaining
how jane foster gets that hammer and it turns out
the way they went with seems like a big callback
to the first thor movie in the classic thor comics
so if you look at this scene that they're filming
here you can see that the asgardians have built
out the rest of new asgard with structures
all over the place since the events of end
game just to make it look more like classic asgard
instead of just a small fishing village on the bay
here it's been a little over two years when the
movie picks up i believe thor love and thunder
takes place after the events of spider-man no
way home after the events of doctor strange 2
multiverse of madness for the most part with a
few exceptions the marvel movies tend to move in
a linear fashion in the timeline but notice you
can see here that they've also taken the time
to turn this spot where odin died on the
cliff side here during ragnarok into a special
shrine and right behind it they've also erected a
special monument for the broken pieces of mjolnir
there's this little special pedestal here that
holds the broken pieces and it was built on the
spot where hella crushed the hammer if you're a
big lord of the rings fan it's a little like the
shrine that elrond and the elves of rivendell
erected to the broken pieces of aragorn sword
Andúril the sword of the king side note too if
you are lord of the rings fan there's a massive
lord of the rings tv show that amazon is in the
middle of filming right now they spent half a
billion dollars on their season one i will be
doing episode videos for that when it releases
next year completely separate from thor though
not related to marvel stuff and in this scene
where they're filming with natalie portman's
jane foster you can see she's wearing just
jeans t-shirt jacket very casual clothing but
they have her floating in the air with her arms
flapping around and it seems like this is jane
foster becoming female thor for the first time and
she's just at this special shrine to the broken
pieces of mjolnir right next to the monument where
odin died so just based on this evidence it seems
like the way they're explaining her becoming thor
and getting a version of the hammer is there
using the power of odin's original enchantment
on the hammer whosoever holds this hammer if
they be worthy shall possess the power of thor
i guess they're saying that just because hella
broke the hammer physically she didn't destroy
odin's enchantment on it and his spell was just so
powerful that literally when the hammer deems her
worthy and she just happens to touch one of the
broken pieces of mjolnir the enchantment repairs
the hammer reforms it but also grants her most of
the same powers as thor including a set of armor
the armor is also another reference to that first
thor movie remember the end of the first movie
when he becomes worthy again when he calls the
hammer and grabs it his armor forms around him
through a magical spell i'm sure there's also a
scientific way of explaining where the pieces of
the armor come from like the armor isn't inside
the hammer it's a powerful enchantment that's
just doing all the heavy lifting just to make
as many hammer jokes as possible they haven't
revealed what her armor is going to look like
or if she'll have the alternate blonde hair that
female thor had in the comics i'm not expecting it
just because we already know that it's jane foster
and in the original mighty thor story that part
of this is based on they did the whole blonde hair
thing as a way to hide her secret identity from
comic book readers till later in the story there's
no reason to hide her identity during the events
of this film but just in terms of her actual
appearance when she's female thor when she's in
the armor think about the way that valkyrie looks
in her white armor during ragnarok or during
endgame she'll be probably about as big as that
when you're talking about relative power levels
the funny thing about asgardians even people like
loki who's obviously frost giant is that even
without ever having worked out a single day in
their lives never lifting weights their genetics
just make them way stronger way more powerful than
normal humans that's how loki is able to soak all
that damage from the hulk thrashing him a normal
person would pop like a balloon if the hulk did
that to them it'd be like homelander on the boys
punching through people's faces just making giant
messes of gore that being said amongst asgardians
you still have vastly different levels of power
like there are normal asgardians who are still
super strong and resilient compared to humans
but thor for example is a lesser god like a legit
lesser god in a cosmic sense so he is way more
powerful than normal asgardians that's why even
the fat version of thor during the final battle
in avengers end game is still crazy powerful dual
wielding against thanos he could still run as
fast as captain america without breaking a sweat
even before he lost all that weight and just
because mjolnir deems jane foster worthy in
reforms for her that doesn't necessarily confirm
anything about thor's actual story during the film
but in the comics he becomes unworthy and
that's the whole twist it was actually nick
fury's fault that he became unworthy too and
because we have gore the godbutcher in the movie
the whole reason why nick fury made him unworthy
or made him feel unworthy was that during this big
fight that they were having in a previous comic
book event he whispers in thor's ear and says
gore was right and on the spot thor just drops
the hammer and it sat there until jane foster came
along later during the mighty thor storyline and
picked it up and became female thor what nick fury
meant though when he said gore was right was the
whole idea that during the gore of the godbutcher
storyline which obviously is informing another big
part of the movie was that the gods people like
thor don't actually care about their subjects
they don't care about helping people gore felt
like the gods only cared about themselves and
thus they didn't deserve to exist that's why
he went on his campaign of trying to kill them all
christian bale playing gore the god butcher during
the movie can't wait to see what he's actually
going to look like we've actually seen him on set
getting ready to film his scenes he did shave his
head i'm assuming some of his appearance will be
a little bit motion capture because even if gore's
face in the movie looks like christian bale's face
there's no way they could do all gore's powers
with the negro sword and the way his cloak works
without using some motion capture but the early
theory now for all these different hammers is
that what happens is thor just happens to be away
from earth when gore first arrives at new asgard
to kill all the gods that he can find and because
asgard is without their protector so to speak
that's why odin's enchantment works for jane
foster thor because while she's nearby she also
happens to be touching mjolnir just off-handedly
and happens to be deemed worthy while gore is in
the process of attacking so it's one of those
situations where the hammer just uses a sort of
magical algorithm and says okay you fulfill all
the requirements bam you are here you will protect
asgard so post all your theories in the comments
below what do you think thor is doing when jane
foster is in the process of becoming a version
of thor and remember a while ago chris hemsworth
did confirm that he was going to continue being
thor in the mcu after the events of thor love
and thunder so it sounds like they're not going to
kill him off or retire him or anything but really
what i'm hoping for i really just want to see thor
get some scenes with a version of silver surfer
and galactus when they introduce new versions of
those characters in the mcu maybe if we're lucky
we'll get some teasers or easter eggs for them
during marvel's first new fantastic four movie
just to explain the scenes that taika was posting
on his instagram and his twitter account these
are all behind the scenes of them filming really
cosmic scenes they're using the giant video wall
technology that they use on the mandalorian taika
watiti obviously directed on the mandalorian he
also played ig-11 but as you can see it
looks kind of like they're standing on a
moon this rock face here that's directly exposed
to the stars so they're using it for very cosmic
scenes that's hard to do practically but what's
going to happen is we'll get a couple more loki
trailers in the next couple of weeks so i'll
do videos for all that stuff as we get ready
for the loki episodes while you wait for
everything click here for my other thor 4
love and thunder first look videos and teasers
and click here for my new doctor strange 2
ghost rider video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!